MARK: HELLO AMERICA, I AM
MARK LEVIN, THIS IS "LIFE,
LIBERTY AND LEVIN."
OUR SHOW TONIGHT IS THE LAST
SHOW BEFORE TUESDAY'S
ELECTION.
VERY IMPORTANT, I KNOW MANY
OF YOU ARE WATCHING.
WHAT DOES THE DEMOCRAT PARTY
STAND FOR?
WE HAD TO FIGHT A CIVIL WAR
IN 1860S TO DEFEAT THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY.
WHEN IT STOOD FOR SLAVERY,
IT WAS ABUSING BLACK PEOPLE,
THEN IT SOUGHT TO BREAK
BREAKAWAY
FROM THE UNION.
WE HAD THE FIGHT THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY REALLY BEFORE
THAT POINT.
TO THE POINT TODAY.
THIS IS A PARTY THAT
NEVER EMBRACED AMERICANISM,
ALWAYS USED RACISM FOR MOST
OF ITS E--
EXISTENCES.
TODAY IT HAS A SORT OF
ANTI-WHITE RACISM.
JOE BIDEN IS HEAD OF
DEMOCRAT PARTY.
HE SPEAKS FOR THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY, AND HE SAYS THINGS TO
AMERICA AND ABOUT AMERICANS
THAT NO PRESIDENT HAS EVER
SAID, EVER.
JOE BIDEN GIVES SPEECHES IN
WHICH HE TRASHES THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
JUST LIKE HILLARY CLINTON
DOES.
JUST LIKE BARACK OBAMA DOES.
THAT 3.
>> METING TO DEMOCRACY.
RACISTS, SEMI FASCISTS.
THIS IS NEW IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
WE'RE NOT USED TO HEARING
SO-CALLED LEADERS TALK ABOUT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THIS WAY
OR HALF OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
IT STARTED WITH OBAMA.
AND IT WAS PICKED UP BY
HILLARY CLINTON.
AND JOE BIDEN HE IS NOT
SMART ENOUGH TO THINK FOR
HIMSELF, HE FIRST CAME
TO SENATE HE PICKED UP THE
LANGUAGE.
HE PICKED UP THE LANGUAGE
AND HATE OF TED KENNEDY.
WHICH WAS USED TO AGAIN
CONSERVATIVES AND
REPUBLICANS AND NOW, OF
COURSE, HE HAS PICKED IT UP
FROM OBAMA AND HILLARY
CLINTON.
SO THIS IS WHAT WE'RE
CONFRONTING IN
THIS ELECTION, JOE BIDEN'S
LANGUAGE, HIS ATTACKS TO
AMERICAN PEOPLE, LINCOLN,
JOHN KENNEDY, RONALD REAGAN,
DONALD TRUMP THEY NEVER
SPOKE ABOUT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THIS WAY.
THEY SPOKE TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
PRAISING THE AMERICAN
THANKS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
BUT THEY DESPISE US, MODERN
DEMOCRAT PARTY DESPISES, WE
THE PEOPLE, THEY DON'T WANT
TO REPRESENT US, THEY WANT
TO RULE OVER US, THAT IS
WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO DO.
LOOK AT CANDIDATES THEY HAVE
NOMINATED.
THIS YEAR TO THE UNITED
STATES SENATE, THE MOST
RADICAL, HATE-AMERICA,
ANTI-PROSPERITY, GROUP OF
CANDIDATES IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
MANDELA BARNES IN WISCONSIN,
WHO WANTS TO OPEN FLOOD
GATES OF OUR PRISONS AND LET
OUT CRIMINALS.
DOWN THE LIST, ULTRA LEFT
WING MARXIST.
AND WARNOCK IN GEORGIA, A
COMPLETE RADICAL
LEFTIST, WHO VOTES FOR HIGH
INFLATION AND NOT TO CLOSE
THE BORDER, AND JOHN
FETTERMAN IN PENNSYLVANIA, A
BERNIE SANDERS KNOCKOFF IF
NOT WORSE, HE WANTED TO OPEN
PRISONS IN PENNSYLVANIA, HE
WAS ON THE PAROLE BOARD,
VOTING BY HIMSELF TO LET
MURDERER AFTER MURDERER OUT
OF PRISON, HE SAID NOTHING
ABOUT HOW HE WOULD SECURE
THE BORDER, ALL OF A SUDDEN
HE IS FOR FRACKING, WE KNOW
HE OPPOSES FRACKING, SHE A
RADICAL, AND SHERRI BEASLEY
IN NORTH CAROLINA, A
HARD-CORE LEFTIST,S THEY ARE
NOT SO-CALLED MODERATES AND
NEVADA, CATHERINE CORTEZ
MASTO.
SHE IS AN INCUMBENT.
WHEN SHE IS SILENT, SHE
VOTING PARTY LINE.
THAT JOE BIDEN RADICAL LINE,
SCHUMER RADICAL LINE.
SHE CAMPAIGNS ON ONE ISSUE.
ABORTION ON DEMAND.
THAT IS PARTIAL-BIRTH
ABORTION.
SHE THINKS THAT NOVEMBER
NEVADANS ARE COMMITTED
TO, THAT AND ARIZONA MARK --
MARK KELLY.
HE PRETENDS TO BE A MOD
YEAH, THE, A FORMER
ASTRONAUT, WHEN HE
FACILITATE RADICAL LEFT
AGENDA, AND UTAH A
.
>> SILENT ENDORSEMENT OF
RINO REPUBLICANS, TO TRY TO
TAKE OUT MR. CONSERVATIVE IN
THE SENATE MIKE LEE.
HE IS A DISGRACE.
HE IS A CHAMELEON AND
MURKOWSKI IN ALASKA
HER BIGGEST BACKER IS
MITCH MCCONNELL.
SHE IS RUNNING AGAINST A
SOLID CITIZEN CANDIDATE WHO
IS A CONSERVATIVE.
KELLY BACKED BY THE PARTY OF
ALASKA.
NEW YORK GOVERNOR HOCHUL IS
A DISASTER.
SHE WAS NOT ELECTED FIRST
TIME.
SHE IS PRO-CRIMINAL,
PRO-ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT AND
PRO-TAXES SHE IS NOT PRO-NEW
YORKERS AND WHITMER IN
MICHIGAN, SHE IS PRO
LOCKDOWNS SHE WOULD BE GREAT
AS A DOMINICAN
A DOMINICAN
REPUBLIC TATE OR -- DICTATOR
IN MICHIGAN.
AND IN WISCONSIN.
A LIGHT WEIGHT.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE PUT UP
FOR CANDIDATES FOR SENATE,
HOUSE AND GOVERNOR, MOST
RADICAL PEOPLE THAT THEY
COULD FIND, WHY?
WHY.
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
TRANSFORM AMERICA.
DON'T YOU REMEMBER FROM
BARACK OBAMA SAID, THEY ARE
DOING IT.
THE DRUG CARTELS IN MEXICO
GETTING FENTANYL FROM
COMMUNIST CHINESE, THEY
CONTROL OUR SOUTHERN BORDER,
WHY?
BECAUSE BIDEN IS ALLOWING
IT.
WHAT HAVE THE DEMOCRATS WHO
SEEKED REELECTION DONE ABOUT
IT, NOTHING, WHAT ARE THEY
DOING GO INFLATION, THEY
CREATED IT, THEY WANT TO
SPEND MORE, THEY SAY MORE
DEFICIT SPENDING WILL REDUCE
INFLATION, REALLY?
THEY ARE NOTON ECONOMIC
ILLITERATES
BUT THEY ARE IDEOLOGICAL
FOOLS, YOU FOLKS WILL HAVE
LESS HEATING OIL THIS
WINTER, YOU CAN THANK THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY, THEY ARE AT
WAR WITH OIL, THEY TRASH THE
OIL COMPANIES AND FOOD
COMPANIES AND FARMERS, THE
BIG DEMOCRAT PARTY IS
DESTROYING AMERICA.
AND HIVELY HOOD FOR AVERAGE
AMERICANS, IF THEY GET TO
THEIR WAY.
THEY WILL DOUBLE TRIPLE
DOWN TO A POINT THAT WE CAN
NEVER  RETURN.
LOOK AT FUNDAMENTALS OF
UNITED STATES WHY ARE WE SO
GREAT AND HAD PROSPERITY AND
FREEDOM.
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IN THIS.
WE BELIEVE IN OUR FOUNDING
AND HISTORY, BUT THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY DOES NOT, THE
PEOPLE TEARING DOWN THE
MONUMENTS BRINGING
PORNOGRAPHY IN OUR SCHOOL
THEY VOTE DEMOCRAT, THE
DEMOCRATS ARE DENIERS THEY
LIKE TO SAY WE'RE ELECTION
DENIERS, DESPITE THE FACT
THEY DENIED ELECTION IN
2000, 2004 AND 2016, THEY
DENY INDIVIDUAL LIBERTY,
PRIVATE PROPERTY RIGHTS,
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY, CIVIL
SOCIETY.
THE RULE OF LAW, WHAT ELSE?
CIVIL STABILITY.
ECONOMIC PREDICTABILITY.
NATIONAL SECURITY.
WHAT ELSE?
THE FAMILY.
MORALITY AND FAITH, THEY ARE
DENIERS ALL RIGHT, THEY WANT
TO IMPOSE THEIR RADICAL
AGENDA ON WE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
IF WE DON'T ACCEPT IT, THEY
BERATE US.
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES ON THE
CONTRARY.
THEY WANT TO DEFEND OUR
COUNTRY, WE HAVE FABULOUS
CANDIDATES RUNNING FOR
OFFICE, VAST MAJORITY ARE
NOT ESTABLISHMENT
REPUBLICANS THEY COME FROM
VARYING BACKGROUNDS AND
EXPERIENCES, BUT THEY AGREE
ON ONE THING, THIS CUN VI IN
COUNTRY IS IN A HELL OF A
BAD WAY, ONLY WAY TO
BEGINNING PROCESS OF WHAT IS
GOING ON TO REMOVE THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE DONE THIS TO
YOU, MAKE SURE OTHER PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO DO MORE ARE THIS
TO YOU NEVER SET FOOT IN THE
CAPITOL BUILDING.
YOU, WE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
ARE A TREMENDOUS TEAM.
A PATRIOT I THINK PEOPLE,
AND WE HAVE SAVED WORLD
MULTIPLE TIMES FROM MARXISM
AND FASCISM.
YOU HAVE SENT YOUR CHILDREN
TO WAR, TO DEFEND PEOPLE AND
COUNTRIES WE KNOW NOTHING
ABOUT, THIS IS A GREAT
COUNTRY DESPITE WHAT OBAMA,
HILLARY CLINTON AND BIDEN
AND THE DEMOCRAT PARTY SAY
ABOUT US.
THAT IS WHAT ELECTION IS
ABOUT, LIBERTY OR TYRANNY, I
SAY LIBERTY.
FOR GOD'S SAKE, MAKE SURE
YOU VOTE TUESDAY, IF YOU
HAVE NOT ALREADY.
AND MAKE SURE YOU TAKE
PEOPLE WITH YOU AND CONTACT
THEM, YOU RT THE THOMAS
PAYNES DO NOT RELY ON PARTY
FIGURERS ON SOMEONE IN DC.
IT IS